Findlay Honda in Centennial hills the
sponsors of this segment are focused on
a different kind of drive this season I
stopped by their dealership to help kick
off their food drive check it out
[Music]
[Applause]
it is always the season of giving for
Finley and we are here at Findlay Hana
Centennial Richard the general sales
manager first before we get to giving
back let's talk about the facility
that's great
um Findlay Honda Centennial Hills we've
been located here for about 16 years now
just off the interstate not more than
15-20 minutes from anywhere in town
convenient very convenient now what do
you guys have here talk about cars and
vehicles inventories is never better
we've got more new and used cars than
we've had in the last 24 months we've
also expanded our remote services to try
to help all the customers that can't get
to us we learned that during the
pandemic we have remote services for
everything from appraising the vehicle
buying your car selling you a car we can
do pretty much any process that's done
here in the store remotely now okay now
Rich from Cars to community tell us why
we're here today
well you're here today because we belong
to the Findlay automotive group I've
been with them 15 years and I've never
seen an organization more dedicated to
giving back to the community I've worked
with three Square in the past Dan
Johnson Our Guest today I've known him
for almost a decade across multiple
stores that I've worked at and it's all
about season and giving so let's get to
the tech presentation sounds great Dan
on behalf of Findlay Honda Centennial
I'd like to present this donation to
yourself and to Three Square thank you
very much thank you Rich this check this
generous gift provides 9 000 meals to
our neighbors in need that's incredible
and tell us more about what three Square
does for the community well three square
is Southern Nevada's only Food Bank
we take care of all the four counties in
southern Nevada
right now there's about 341 000 people
that are food insecure so that's one in
seven
so we work on it no one's going hungry
here because we have great supporters
Finley and um everyone's getting fed
because of folks like this rich now I
hear that giving back to three Square
doesn't stop here that's correct the
check in the drill Nation are just the
start of our holiday food drive with
three Square all of our donations are
asked to be bought to Findlay Honda
Centennial at 7494 West Azure drive we
will be accepting all donations from now
until December 17th that is great we are
continuing giving back to three Square
through the holidays and Beyond
congratulations on the donation today
Dan thank you thank you Rich and thank
you for all the work you're doing
thank you to Findlay Honda and
Centennial Hills for sponsoring that
segment call
702-982-4200 or just visit
findleyhonda.com for more information
they also have a special offer for you
as a Kelly as a Kelly Blue book buying
Center Findlay Honda Centennial can
provide an instant cash offer to
purchase your vehicle that's great which